pourquoi nos fiches castaldi est accusé
de suivre les traces de son père
benjamin ah bah voilà ça y
est bbbb là
et il est bon il a il a trop peu à dexia
il a trompé sa meuf et ouais addiction
pendant le tournage du reste du monde
simon castaldi a trompé sa chérie
mathias et des chats voilà vous allez
rennais
voilà regardez regardez cet appel
[Applaudissements]
je ne veux pas devoir et toi tu adores
mort le chinois quand ils menacent un
dégagement ce que toi tu es morte c'est
là où il devra 300 karting en filmant
des morts
[Musique]
voilà encore un qui va payer beaucoup de
pension alimentaire
bien sûr chez decca stadio payons pas
les pensions alimentaires de père en
fils vous savez un alors qu'ici c'est
passionnant mais il a fait il a fait un
mot assez joli il a dit voilà je suis
désolé j'ai 22 ans ça arrive à tout le
monde voilà il a fait un très joli
message trouve sur twitter lui demander
pardon à ça il a trompé avec la cette
personne ne s'attendait à ça c'est ça
c'est l'addiction
ça s'est même qui l'a trompée elle
woods
le carton d'exigence qu'il a trompé non
c'est lui qui l'a trompée elle donc qu
est l d'encaisser la femme trompée
tromper voilà on a quand même ses
coordonnées aucun
c'est vous avec l'américaine nan mais
c'est pour nous avec
alors que la protéine whey avec les
ouïes la raison écoulé d'où mais vous
[Rires]
à ninon wayne on est là il est bien là
et bien bien non
tout witter le shark et tout lui tape
dessus en bas de ça va mais en vrai ce
que je me suis dit je me suis en vrai de
vrai c'est pas de sa faute moi je pars
du principe que non quand élevé par un
char où tu deviens charreaux à
savoir de moi c'est moi j'ai pris un
super g alors que ses frères il est
super mais il est super pardon mais
benji tu veux pas sortir de cette galère
enfin choix et l'a griffé tue pas de
soldats mais qui fait au
bout du compte c'est sympa ça m'a l'air
assez vite donc voilà qui produit ça
c'est vous je crois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon ben voilà c'est pas moi c'est génial
si ça veut et lahi la marche n'est
pas très loin voilà cela il faut garder
un jour et partir à oizon du barracuda
hyper ça arrive à tout le monde oui sans
déconner gétaz zanzibar d1
mais où et quand successeur ou la mort
tu me pousser parce que c'est la
dernière personne que tu as pécho
t'amènera joinville-le-pont
foncé benhaim par contre par an qu'un
safari pas après
l'algérie fait content d'être là daniel
est pas payée
spectateurs médias daniel moreau n'est
pas payée sur cinq a dit rien
[Applaudissements]
jeu souleymane suleiman
on
souleymane calme toi mon bébé non parce
qu'elle travaille au bureau la journée à
oui pareil elle fournit aussi
j'ai jamais fait qu'au bureau schéma
complet de fonctions
aident quand il fait pourquoi je te
voici un bureau d'études fait
des fiches pour des livres dont on
entend que jamais moi j'aimerais que
j'ai quoi à voir là dedans c'est toi qui
l'a payé je sais pas mais elle fait des
fiches pour des livres va falloir quand
même lieu des 100
g l'impression que ça fait des semaines
que nous enfume
question quelle chanteuse a fait
polémique après avoir posté des vidéos
un peu olé olé sur les réseaux sociaux
gilles verdez tepito non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est bon c'est bon t'as vu ta
nouvelle famille de vraiment content
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
américains
et britney spears a fait parler d'elle
parce que on l'a vu ça nulle sur une
vidéo gta les sorties de la tutelle de
son père ça ne va pas du tout elle est
très malade elle est détruite sous la
dent donc oui mais elle fait n'importe
quoi mais dont seul à sauver
alors britney spears mais aussi contre
13 à la fois il a pété il a fait au
petit
gars des beautés spurs et
sookie échec
comme tout
[Musique]
moment
l'odeur
quand même très sympa non mais c'est fou
et moi moi j'ai toujours téléphone
tendresse match à 13 ans sous tutelle
d'un cancer dont on dit qu'il a comme
avisés de cette tutelle moi ma cousine
s'appelle britney parce qu'on qui fait
tellement britney dans la famille qu'on
la britney spears qu'on appelait
britannique ça va être britney alone à
dents britney chiche
c'est une cousine
whitney shish taouk
saage et des deux guerres
c'est vrai j'adore son mât me
tiens question pour l'instant il ya un
point partout et sachets je vous dirai
ce que vous allez gagner à la fin un
beau cadeau pour le grand ghetto caution
bancaire
calme toi qui es c'est vrai que je kiffe
britney oui je sais que lapin qui la
coupe kelly est fan de britney est une
terre bien britney spears non c'est pas
trop mon truc d'accord daniel c'est pas
mon truc mais je la plains elle a vécu
treize ans d'enfer et franchement et
puis franchement bombe a montré ses
seins
c'est moi qui fais de moi tu fais la
même vidéo instinct norton barbe et si
je devais montrer un truc ce serait
messin bah ouais
il ya des gens qui m'attendent
[Applaudissements]
ça va c'est mon pire qu'a déclaré
qu a déclaré jean marie bigard après le
passage de sa productrice dans tpm pays
reçoit cas
déclarés volés baby tôt db là
il a déclaré qu'il ne partirait jamais
faire le spectacle avec dieudonné que
c'était fini c'est que c'était peut-être
une crasse du passé mais aucunement
envie de faire un spectacle avec
dieudonné je prends à la réponse de
[Applaudissements]
gilles toute la vérité j'aimerais savoir
ici à toi tu pour le vch à stopper
ce que nous a déjà menés en boisson
mais ça mais c'est toujours non mais oui
mediaimpression que corp et en plus une
verrue
date a déjà fait 6 t2 mal comme ça alors
les shérif qui pense d'ailleurs que jean
marie vianney tissé autour de la table
ce que je n'ai pas posé la question hier
aurait dû faire ce spectacle avec donné
puisque jean marie a dit cook ou les
amis pour ceux qui ont regardé tpp hier
c'est qu'il y aura encore un doute je ne
ferai jamais de spectacle avec dieudonné
sur quels sous quelle forme que ce soit
j'invite ceux qui ont acheté des places
pour ce spectacle allait se faire
rembourser si christelle tamis donc sa
productrice peut me faire un procès
j'attends sereinement paix et amour pépé
einstein en parler castaldi enfin bien
sûr alors qu'ils pensaient est ce qu'on
a je tiens une personne ici qui pensent
qu'il aurait dû faire ce spectacle
personnes ont
apprécié c'est très clair à part pour
gagner de l'argent parce que c'était
vendeur il avait vendu 30 mille places
et moi ce qui me gêne ce qui met mal à
l'aise dans cette histoire c'est qu'on a
l'impression qu'il est sous influence et
qui a des gens qui veulent profiter de
lui il ya cette histoire de twitter
quelqu'un a pris la parole à sa place
ensuite il reprend les comptes de les
codes de ses réseaux pour dire non en
fait je pense pas ça et moi sa
productrice hier elle m'a mis
extrêmement mal à l'aise on a vraiment
l'impression qu'elle le profiter lui et
c'est terrible elle protège pas son
artiste non mes jambes a rien n'a pas
besoin surtout parce qu'il a beaucoup de
talent tout seul il est incroyable il
faut qu'il écrirait la doc taxer google
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours défendue
c'est vrai
il a beaucoup de talent ah oui talent le
clan nouveau spectacle c'est tout tu vas
dire combien de fois dire quoi il a du
talent
je serai pouvoir aller pas tout à
l'heure
pendant la pub c'est elle c'est le seul
humoriste de tous les temps avoir rempli
le stade de france à bercy on l'a fait
dans la salle personne versilia booba
qui va remplir le stade de france et
social ces le so lu ment il s'y est
rendu c'est fou
c'est anita déjà rempli quoi toi on sait
[Applaudissements]
tu cherches et merci l'élégance à la
française
quelle personnalité a ravivé sans le
vouloir une théorie selon laquelle
l'homme ne serait jamais allé sur la
lune
mais biteau db là
on a dit haye sur ma vie je crois
qu'elle faisait un avc
j'ai fait la piste elles doivent sans
déconner j'étais à deux doigts de donner
mais la wii tandis que ça désaltère bien
je te jure que ça va bien aller le tout
les
indices cul sur la tête jean mais sans
déconner c'est que c'est pas mal c'est
pas nul c'est pas vrai je te dis que
soit la question soummam l ordre d'idées
nous thomas pesquet bien sûr bien sûr
ces heureuses ouais super de gagner et
au
dîner avec moi gagner
dans la ville
[Applaudissements]
oui on a dîné à gagner avec moi donc je
prends la tête et tous en tête à tête à
queue
[Applaudissements]
ouais en fait at elle bien entendu début
thomas pesquet regarder ce qu'il a dit
mission qui va décoller avec sa pelle
artemis 1 c'est vraiment la répétition
générale d'artémis 2 ça va être la même
avec un équipage artemis 3 donc dans
trois ans trois ans peut-être quatre ans
et bien ce sera le grand retour de
l'homme et de la femme sur la lune douze
hommes tous américains pour l'instant où
marcher sur la lune déjà est ce que vous
serez le 13e à y laisser votre empreinte
thomas pesquet on va tous se porter
volontaire on verra bien qui marchera
sur la table au
prochain tour si on regarde la ville a
rien pas dit ça thomas puisqu'il a dit
le prochain mais il vient de faire un
trait dessus père voit où il est très
énervé en disant arrêtez avec vos
théories jamais dit ça va être pensé que
je n'aurais d'îlots prochain ce sera
question ce sera non sécurisé aurait
elle doit aller sur la lune ah ouais ah
ah bon mais j'aurais préféré que vous y
alliez
non mais franchement ça vous fascine les
spas j'adore mois ci un voyage n'est ce
pas cela il ya les petites et avons un
ami pour cent mille euros sont mises en
rien pour vous qui revient pour une
quatrième
ou mais c'est quoi ces mots là comme le
pass navigo comme le précise
delphine devrait pas aller sur la lune
moi ça me fait très peur d'aller à west
la mer la lune le laisse pas c'est tout
non mr henry ouais bah jamais chez
castadi de retenue
mais je te le dis je peux dire que j'ai
réveillé un soin jours à venir c'est la
pleine lune en avc moi j'ai vu votre
lune en revanche oui à votre
ils m'accueillent me chauffer sydney
jour ils dorment à la maison juste avec
les enfants je suis allé le matin je les
réveiller j'ai mis mes fesses dans ccb
pas le matin c'était dans la nuit
c'était sympa c'est très sympa à écouter
moi j'évite et le large en avait encore
un peu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]